Am I talking too fast?
No. I don’t think so.
No? Okay.
The polls reveal some interesting information
about millennials and foreign policy.
First off, millennials are far less likely
than their parents or their grandparents to
agree with the statement:
“America is the greatest country in the
world.”
In fact, only 32% of millennials agree with
that according to a Pew poll from 2014
whereas 50% of baby boomers agree with that
and 64% of the baby boomers’ parents agree
with that—so millennials’ grandparents—agree
with that.
When you look at the Chicago Council polling
from 2014, only about 50% of millennials agree
with the statement that:
“America should stay engaged in the world.”
What are the implications of this?
Well, currently we’re seeing much more support
for isolationist and multilateralist policies
and that manifests itself in support for candidates
like Bernie Sanders.
What are the long-term implications? That’s
a little bit harder to say.
Of course, if you look at the baby boomers’
generation in the 1960s and 1970s, they violently
opposed the Vietnam War
but eventually they became more confident
in America’s leadership role.
Is that something that we’re going to see
from millennials?
It’s too soon to tell.
Do you think that millennials
will eventually come around to valuing America’s
leadership role the way that their parents’
generation did?
Or do you think that what we’re seeing is
a fundamental shift in the way Americans view
foreign policy?
Let us know in the comments section
and also let us know if there are any other
topics you’d like AEI scholars to cover
in 60 Seconds.